in this morning's ion money what you
need to know before filing your taxes in
just the first week of this tax season
the IRS says it processed nearly 13
million returns mine was not one of them
and they should almost four point three
million refunds I won't be getting one
of those the filing deadline is April
15th of course CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is here with some
reminders for this tax season my
favorite time of the year Jill good
morning my favorite time you were
kidding what's what's what's changed for
this year not a lot has changed every
year the IRS makes some inflation
adjustments so the brackets aren't
exactly the same and the deduction
amounts aren't exactly the same but
there are three major issues that are
different this year than last year right
after the tax law changed number one is
that you no longer have to pay a penalty
if you did not have health insurance
that individual mandate it went to zero
so it's gone no tax forms you have to
file if you got divorced last year and
there is some alimony payment alimony is
basically now tax neutral meaning if you
pay alimony you don't get to deduct it
but if you receive alimony you don't
have to claim it if you were a divorce
prior to 2019 the old rules apply and
finally if you are going to be able to
deduct medical expenses you have to be
an itemized ER and it has to be more
than seven and a half percent of your
adjusted gross income so those are the
big changes for this year so what
documents exactly do you need to file
and what's the easiest way to file
well the documents should have already
come in the w2's the 1099 s you might
have gotten a statement maybe from your
mortgage company your bank accounts
you'll gather up all these documents but
again most of this stuff should be in
grab your old tax return let that be a
guide and then just know this the
majority of people who are filing taxes
can qualify for something called Free
File this is an IRS program with
software companies so you get the
software and the filing is for free if
you make less than sixty nine thousand
dollars the IRS says that's about a
hundred million tax payers know if you
make less than sixty nine thousand
dollars you probably don't need to pay
for any tax services that's what you're
staying online as easiest way to file
apps
you should be electronic fewer errors
that we people obviously waiting for
refunds how long do they typically have
to wait usually about three weeks and
and if it's longer than that then of
course you should go out and try to
contact the IRS just two other things
that I should mention there is a
volunteer service called Vita the
Volunteer Income Tax Assistance Program
and the tax counseling for the elderly
program if you go to IRS gov these are
two fantastic resources for people who
may not have English as a first language
or older people so there are resources
there irs.gov/aca in another segment all
right oh thank you oh it's good to have
you here and if you're wondering what
your tax bracket is for the 2019 tax
year go to cBS This Morning Calm to find
out where you land